>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the library of Congress.
I have the great honor
and pleasure as head
of the Library's new division,
National and International Outreach,
of welcoming you here this evening
for the Living Legend Award.
First of all, I want
to acknowledge members
of the diplomatic community
who are with us tonight.
Among them are a number of
diplomats from countries
that have figured large
in the life and career
of our awardee, Mario Vargas Llosa.
Please welcome Ambassador
Luis Miguel Castilla of Peru.
[ Applause ]
I cannot -- Spain's
Ambassador, Ramon Gil-Casares.
[ Applause ]
The Mexican Ambassador,
Miguel Basanez.
[ Applause ]
Ambassador Martin Lousteau
of Argentina.
[ Applause ]
Sweden's Deputy Chief of
Mission, Goran Lithell.
[ Applause ]
And the former Ambassador from
the United States to Peru,
Ambassador Alexander Watson.
[ Applause ]
We are delighted to have all of you
join us for this happy occasion.
I also want to welcome our most
recent Living Legend Awardee,
whose award was conferred
last November.
She is a vibrant force
in the musical world,
the prodigiously talented
Marta Castals Istomin.
[ Applause ]
And last, but certainly not least,
I would like to recognize
the individual responsible
for this award, the man who
has played a pivotal role
in naming the Living Legends
for the last 16 years,
Librarian of Congress
Emeritus James H. Billington.
[ Applause ]
Thank you also to the
distinguished novelists and scholars
who informed us so richly
about Mario Vargas Llosa's work
in this afternoon's symposium.
You'll find their names
listed in your program.
They've come a long way to
pay homage to this awardee.
Let's give them a big hand.
[ Applause ]
The Living Legend Award was
inaugurated 16 years ago
in the year 2000, exactly
200 years after the formation
of the Library of Congress.
The then-Librarian of Congress,
James Billington, was seeking a way
to mark the Library's bicentennial
by celebrating artists, scholars,
and professionals across
disciplines,
individuals who had made lasting
impressions on American culture.
Their fields might be science,
or literature, or medicine,
or the media, or politics, or
entertainment, or the fine arts.
It didn't matter, but their
work needed to be trailblazing
in some way, transformational,
electric, enduring.
And their contributions had
to say something important
about what it means to be American
and what it means for Americans
to be citizens of the world.
This is why we are
gathered here tonight,
to celebrate the many
accomplishments
of a writer who's had
a profound effect
on the American reading
public, the Peruvian novelist
and essayist Mario Vargas Llosa.
Ladies and gentlemen,
without further ado,
we offer a brief history
of this remarkable writer.
Let's roll the video, please.
[ Music ]
>> If anything can be said
to define Mario Vargas Llosa,
it is his passion for words, a
passion that leaps exuberantly
from genre to genre, from
spoken to written works.
He is best known for his
fiction, which can be spirited,
whimsical, or deadly serious.
His novels are well-known
for exposing human frailties
and plumbing dark chapters
of human history.
But fiction is not his only domain.
He has excelled in
theater, journalism,
literary criticism, opinion.
He has given us drama,
memoir, critical essays,
social and political commentary,
scholarly argument,
literary scholarship.
And he has done so with
rare intellectual vigor
and a keen appreciation
of the human heart.
He learned to read at the age
of five in a Catholic school
in Cochabamba, Bolivia, where he and
his mother were living at the time.
It was reading, he says, that opened
the door to a life of writing.
Jorge Mario Pedro Vargas
Llosa was born on March 28th,
1936 in Arequipa, Peru, but he spent
his early childhood years in Bolivia
where he was raised by his mother
and his grandfather,
a Peruvian diplomat.
He moved to Piura,
Peru when he was 10,
and shortly thereafter his parents,
who had been divorced
before he was born,
were reunited and resettled in Lima.
When Mario was 14, his father
sent him to the military academy
that became the inspiration for
his novel "The Time of the Hero."
It was there, steeped in
the rigors of military life,
that Vargas Llosa developed
the second greatest passion
of his career, a deep
regard for freedom.
>> Even as he was being prepared for
a military career he began working
for local newspapers, first in Lima
at the age of 16, and then in Piura.
In 1952 he saw his first play,
"The Flight of the Inca,"
come to life onstage in Piura.
It was the beginning of a lifelong
love affair with storytelling.
Convinced that his future was in
words, he decided to study law
and literature at the
University of San Marcos in Lima.
While still a student he
married his first wife,
Julia Urquidi, at the age of 19.
Graduating from San Marcos in
1958, he won a scholarship to study
at Complutense University in Madrid,
where he received a Doctorate
in Philosophy and Literature.
He went on to Paris, hoping to
win another scholarship there.
And when those hopes were dashed,
he began writing stories in earnest.
To make ends meet he worked as a
reporter for Agence France-Presse
and the French National
Television Network.
It was in Paris, he says, that
he began reading literature
from other Latin American countries,
and eventually met the
Chilean poet Pablo Neruda,
the Cuban novelist Alejo Carpentier,
and the Argentine writer
Jorge Luis Borges.
In Paris, too, Vargas Llosa became
part of the historic flourishing
of literature now known as
the Latin American Boom.
A cadre of brilliant young
writers who inspired one another
to write the landmark Latin American
masterpieces of the '60s and '70s.
They were Gabriel Garcia Marquez,
Jose Donoso, Jorge Edwards,
Carlos Fuentes, Julio Cortazar,
and of course, Mario Vargas Llosa.
Within a few years they would all
be read in English and translated
into languages around the world.
Vargas Llosa's first published
work, a collection of short stories,
was received favorably,
but it was his first novel,
"The Time of the Hero," published in
1963, with it's penetrating portrait
of an entrenched military
establishment in Peru,
that earned him a coveted
prize in Spain,
and an immediate place among the
most celebrated young writers
of Latin America.
His first marriage
dissolved at about that time,
and he married his
cousin Patricia Llosa,
by whom he would eventually
have three children,
Alvaro, Gonzalo, and Morgana.
His second novel, "The Green
House," about a legendary brothel
for soldiers in the Peruvian jungle,
won him even more accolades
and readers.
Every book since has been a
departure from the one before,
alternating from humorous,
even erotic flights of fancy,
to pivotal questions of history.
He has given us in all more than
a dozen unforgettable novels
and a wide variety of nonfiction.
Among these are "Conversation in
the Cathedral," "Captain Pantoja
and the Special Service," "Aunt
Julia and the Script Writer,"
"The War at the End of the World,"
"Who Killed Palomino Molero?"
"In Praise of the Stepmother,"
"Death in the Andes,"
"A Fish in the Water," "The
Notebooks of Don Rigoberto,"
"Letters to a Young Novelist,"
"The Feast of the Goat,"
"The Way to Paradise," "The Bad
Girl," "The Dream of the Celt,"
and most recently,
"The Discreet Hero."
For this remarkably diverse work
in letters he has been awarded
all the major literary prizes
in Spain and Latin America.
He has been decorated
by France, Mexico, Peru,
Nicaragua, The Dominican Republic.
He has been accorded a
title of Spanish nobility.
He has been awarded the Nobel Prize.
But these contributions are not
confined to the pages of his books.
For many decades now this writer
and thinker has been a tireless
participant on the world stage.
He has taught at a number
of prominent universities throughout
Europe and the United States.
He has participated in
theatrical works not only as writer
or director, but as actor.
He had taken an active
part in world commentary,
whether it be about arts,
politics, or culture.
He has lectured widely about the
relevance of the arts in human life.
>> He has been President
of PEN International.
He has run a vigorous campaign for
the Presidency of his native land
>> Mario Vargas Llosa has,
in short, been a passionate,
vibrant force not only in the
realm of the imagination and ideas,
but in the larger sphere
of human affairs.
If the Library of Congress' Living
Legend Award is meant to honor those
who have made significant
contributions
to our cultural heritage, then Mario
Vargas Llosa is eminently deserving
of this prize.
There are few who have done
so much to bring luster
to Spanish-language
letters and enrich culture
in the 20th and 21st centuries.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
the Ambassador of Peru
to the United States of
America, Luis Miguel Castilla.
[ Applause ]
>> Luis Miguel Castilla:
I'm truly honored to be part
of this important celebration.
First of all, I would like to
thank the Library of Congress
for generally hosting us
this evening on the occasion
of bestowing a special
recognition upon Mario Vargas Llosa.
I would also like to acknowledge
a brilliant Peruvian novelist
and journalist, Marie Arana,
who has been instrumental
in putting together
this important event.
Gracias, Marie.
[ Applause ]
Indeed, this time Mario Vargas
Llosa is being given the prestigious
Living Legend Award,
which the Library
of Congress confers upon prominent
figures whose career have made an
impact in a unique and creative
way in the American community,
contributing to its development
and its diverse cultural heritage.
Mario, who received the
Nobel Prize in literature
in 2010 is making history again,
this time in the United States,
receiving a distinction previously
conferred to artists, writers,
thinkers, social activists,
politicians,
and even sports figures, thereby
joining his name with that
of the influential economist
John Kenneth Galbraith,
and the no-less-significant
political scientist George Kennan,
the accomplished photographer
Annie Leibovitz,
the brilliant guitarist B.B.
King, among many others.
This is undoubtedly a unique award
honoring distinguished figures
who contributed to the
endeavors of a community
with deeply-rooted traditions
and values of its own,
and upon which it has emerged as one
of the most influential
living cultures in the world.
I am very proud as a fellow
Peruvian of Mario's accomplishments
which have contributed to
placing very high the name
of our country not only in the
U.S., but around the world.
In this particular case,
the fact of being in one
of the most important
libraries in the world,
in the heart of Washington, and in
one of the most vibrant democracies
on the planet, demonstrates
importance
of Mario's work while
acknowledging his personal qualities
and a lifetime struggle for
democratic values and freedom.
Mario Vargas Llosa has proven
to be a great promoter
of the Peruvian culture.
Through Mario's books one
can learn about a complex
and fascinating country like Peru.
In his books, such as
"La Ciudad y los Perros,"
"Pantaleon y las Visitadoras," and
"La Casa Verde," among many others,
readers discover a mysterious
country with overlapping,
conflicting, and sometimes
contradictory realities,
representing exceptional
testimonies of the variety,
wealth, and diversity of Peru.
On a personal note, as many
Peruvians of my generation,
I have learned a great
deal from Mario's novels,
spending hours devouring his books
and learning about our own history,
its richness and paradoxes.
As him, I grew up in Miraflores.
My father attended the same
Leoncio Prado military school.
The first play I ever attended was
"La Senorita de Tacna" 35 years ago.
And the first time I personally
met Mario was almost five years ago
during a brilliant presentation
at the Cervantes Institute
in New York City.
In all truth, I have been
captivated throughout my life
by his story telling and
his skillful capabilities
of enthralling his readers page
after page, transporting them
from the streets of Santa
Domingo in "La Fiesta del Chivo,"
to Lima's old Barrios Altos quarter
in his most recent
novel "Cinco Esquinas."
Not only has Mario's
literary work been important,
but also his outstanding
journalistic work throughout
his life.
From his first articles in local
newspapers, like La Cronica
and La Industria, through
his recognized [speaking
in foreign language] column,
published in more than 20 countries,
Mario comes across as a
keen observer of the reality
of our times, and with a sharp
pen convinces us again and again
of the importance of freedom
and democratic values,
deeply analyzing global current
affairs from his unique perspective.
And as Mario once states, I
quote, "It is very difficult
for a Latin American
writer to avoid politics.
Literature is an expression of life,
and you cannot eradicate
politics from life."
Ladies and gentlemen, a few
days ago on the occasion
of celebrating Mario's 80th
birthday, a seminar was held
in Madrid [speaking in foreign
language] culture, ideas,
and freedom, during which Spain's
President Mariano Rajoy said
that Mario, I quote, "Embodies
the reaffirmation of freedom
and rejection of indifference."
Adding that, quote, "He's our
only Nobel Prize Laureate alive,
and is a hero of the freedom that
has made Latin America, Spain,
and the Hispanic community
big in the world."
I cannot agree more with the
remarks of President Rajoy.
Mario is an example cautioning
us of the danger of falling
into the illusion of thinking
from the comfort of our homes,
that the benefits we enjoy in the
free world are already established
and everlasting, when the
truth is that it is necessary
to fight for them every day.
People like Mario are
those who wage the battles.
This is what I consider
the main value
of Mario Vargas Llosa's literary
and journalistic work which cautions
and encourages never
to stop fighting
for what we believe is right
and valuable, not only in terms
of ourselves, our community,
but also of humankind at large.
Muchas gracias, Mario.
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, the Acting
Librarian of Congress, David Mao.
[ Applause ]
>> David Mao: Good evening, ladies
and gentlemen, and thank you,
Ambassador Castilla, for
those wonderful remarks.
It's an honor to have you and others
from the diplomatic core
join us this evening
for this wonderful ceremony.
We're very, very delighted
to have so many folks here
to help us celebrate this evening.
Friends, family, all of those who
have played a part in the life
and career of tonight's Living
Legend Awardee, Mario Vargas Llosa.
This may be the first time for many
of you to be here at the Library
of Congress, so I want
to take a few seconds
and tell you a little bit about us.
We are the library that was
founded in 1800 for Congress.
But when we were founded in 1800
we were a small reference library
for the members of Congress
-- for members of Congress,
just a few books and some maps.
But over the last 216
years we have grown
to become the world's
largest library,
with more than 162 million items,
including 32 million books
in over 470 languages.
And quite a few of them
belong to our awardee tonight.
We also have over 60 million
manuscripts, millions of maps,
films, newspapers, sheet music,
photographic images and prints,
all part of our comprehensive
collection of the culture
of the world and the United States.
Now of particular note, the
Library has a magnificent collection
of Latin American and
Luso-Hispanic treasures,
and these collections are
highlighted quite often
in our exhibits, in our
publications, in our reading rooms,
and in our many free public
events like those today.
So I hope today's program -- this
evening's program and the symposia
from this afternoon, inspires
you to come back often
to visit us again and again.
Now it is my great pleasure
and privilege to award
to Mario Vargas Llosa the Library
of Congress Living Legend Award.
The prize, as you have heard
mentioned this evening,
is one that honors those
who have contributed greatly
to the cultural life of Americans.
And since the Library's
bicentennial in 2000,
we have conferred this award
on just select individuals
who have inspired the American
public through exemplary work.
In their fields they've left
great legacies to the world.
And certainly Mario Vargas Llosa
is one of those select individuals.
As Dr. James Billington, now the
Librarian of Congress Emeritus,
put it -- and I should say that
we are very, very delighted
to have Librarian of Congress
Emeritus and Ms. Billington
with us here this evening.
They worked tirelessly
together for almost 30 years
for this great institution, and
-- yes, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
And we're so proud that
we can continue his vision
of awarding a Living
Legend Award here tonight.
So this is what Dr. Billington
said about our awardee tonight,
and I quote, "He is a writer in
every sense of the word, a novelist,
a scholar, a public intellectual,
a playwright, an essayist,
a literary critic, most
importantly, a teacher.
And he's a brilliant champion of
the Latin American experience."
Mr. Vargas Llosa has produced a
vast amount of ground-breaking work
in the realm of letters
and literary criticism.
He's a thinker who
has greatly brought
in the cultural conversation
in this hemisphere.
and during a very long career he
has entertained us, delighted us,
and informed us as only
a great novelist can do.
His fiction reveals a profound
understanding of the human spirit
and the human heart, and
the logic and illogic
of the Latin American character.
His essays and nonfiction
work have tried
to clarify a continent's
realities, its politics, its quirks,
and its hierarchies, its
triumphs, and its tragedies.
He has brought South
American history to life
and shown us the ways that history
lives on in all of its inheritors.
Mario Vargas Llosa is, in short, a
unique spokesman for the Americas,
a literary force whose fiction
and nonfiction works have stimulated
readers in a multitude of languages,
and whose legacy is bound to last
for many generations to come.
We at the Library of
Congress are very,
very proud to confer
this tribute on him.
So please join me in welcoming
and celebrating Mario Vargas Llosa
as we invite him to
the stage this evening
[ Applause ]
At this time we have a very
special part of the program.
We will have an interview
of Mr. Vargas Llosa.
And to do that I want to welcome
Marie Arana, wonderful author,
literary critic, and currently
the Chair of the Cultures
of the Countries of the
South here at the Library
of Congress' John W. Kluge Center.
So please welcome Marie
Arana to the stage.
[ Applause ]
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Marie Arana: Congratulations
to Mario.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Thank you.
>> Marie Arana: This
is a very special --
well, Mario, it's a very
great pleasure for me
for a million reasons to
have you win this award.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Thank you, Marie.
>> Marie Arana: It --
as a Peruvian-American,
as someone who has spent
her lifetime in books
and who has admired you and
known you for so many years --
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Absolutely.
>> Marie Arana: -- it is really
a very special moment for me,
and I'm very grateful to be here
to have this conversation with you.
These last few years
have brought many reasons
to celebrate you, the
Nobel of course.
There have been many
prizes, among them the --
a prize for the citizen
of Madrid, you know.
And not to mention the singular
honor of being chosen as an author
of "La Bibliotheque de la Pleiade,"
which is a tremendous honor, who --
among whose ranks are
the distinguished authors
such as Andre Gide, and Milan
Kundera, and Andre Malraux.
And so you have -- you are now
in this extraordinary rank,
and have been called the
most important writer
of your generation in Latin America.
So now you have to add to
these tributes the Library
of Congress Living Legend Award.
And I want to ask you,
what does it mean to you?
Could you tell us a little bit about
what it means to you, number one,
to have the Living Legend Award, and
number two, in a more general way,
to receive this from the Library
of Congress, which you know
so well for so many years?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Well, I am
deeply grateful, Marie, of course,
to the Library of Congress
for honoring me
with this Living Legend Award.
It's very generous.
I don't think I deserve it.
Legend is something so big, so
permanent, that I don't really feel
that I can become a living legend.
Living, yes.
Living [laughter] --
I think I am living.
But not a legend.
It's just generosity of
the Library of Congress,
and of course, I am very grateful.
I know that to receive an award
is also to receive a mandate.
A mandate of rigor, of
responsibility in what you do,
in what you write, in what you
say, as a public intellectual.
And of course what
can I say, it's --
that I will do my best to
not disappoint you and not
to be too far away
of what this medal,
this Living Legend Award, signifies.
You know, Marie, writing
is a solitary business.
We -- you are a writer yourself,
so you know that in order
to write we isolate
ourselves, and we cut in a way
with the environment,
because this is the only way
in which we can produce
this alternative reality
which is the literary fiction.
And usually writers work in total
uncertainty about what is going
to happen with what
you write afterward,
when it becomes a book
and reach the readers.
In that sense, you know, to
receive a public recognition,
as it is the case of
a literary award,
is something extremely
encouraging, because it means --
you want this to mean that what
you do, sometimes with great effort
and spending a lot of time
and energy in what you do,
is not useless, is
something that reach the mind,
the heart of certain people, and
maybe help these people to live.
This is what is great
about books, you know.
I learned to read when
I was five years old,
and I remember how life
became so rich, so intense,
the way in which my life became
a permanent adventure, you know,
something that was
extremely much more important
than the real life that I had.
So if this is something that we can
produce in our effort of communicate
with the readers, it's
of course the best reward
that a writer can receive, no?
>> Marie Arana: Absolutely.
Well, you say something very
important about writing.
Of course, there's no more
solitary experience in the world
than being a writer
and working alone,
and setting down your
thoughts alone.
But there's also the solitary
experience of being a reader.
And what has always been
extraordinary to me is
that a book is an inanimate subject.
It's -- it doesn't mean anything
until somebody picks it up,
and there is that bridge created
between you and the reader.
So it's an extraordinary
thing to me that you point
out the solitary nature of
writing, which is also very true
for the reader, do you not think?
That it --
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Oh, yes.
I think it's a great mystery for a
writer to thinking what will happen
when the book that you are
writing reach the readers.
If the book reaches the readers,
because sometimes it doesn't, no?
Sometimes there is a
feeling of failure.
I always think in the tragic case
of Giuseppe di Lampedusa,
a very great writer.
I think that he wrote one
of the greatest novels
of the 20th century,
"Il Gattopardo."
He worked very hard in this master
work, and then when he finished --
he was a very cultivated man with
the -- he spoke several languages,
and he had written beautiful essays
about the English writers,
for example.
And he tried to find a publisher
for his book, and seven --
the seven most important publishing
houses of Italy rejected his book.
And then he died before
his book was published.
So I always think in his
case as the most tragic case.
He wrote a master work,
a real master work,
a very great, great novel.
And he couldn't find a publisher.
And when the book was published
-- because Giorgio Bassani,
an Italian writer, finally
discovered the manuscript and said,
"Well, but this is a master work.
This book should be published," and
effectively the book was published.
And the book became immediately
-- immediately a best-seller.
And everybody recognizing "Il
Gattopardo" a real master work.
So what a tragic case,
what sad story, no?
>> Marie Arana: Yes.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: So some
writers, we are very fortunate,
you know, to be recognized.
And it's difficult not to
think in all these colleagues,
these fellow writers, who
were not so fortunate as us.
And sometimes, as is the case
of Giuseppe di Lampedusa,
were tragically rejected
because the blindness
of his contemporary people.
>> Marie Arana: Absolutely.
This is the important part
of being, as you said,
living is a very important
part of this award [laughter].
I want to talk about the
breadth of your work.
What is really most remarkable
to me about your career, Mario --
and it's surely remarkable
to everyone who's sitting
in this audience -- is that very
fact, the breadth, the range.
The video gave us a notion of
that range, although it did leave
out your most recent novel,
"Cinco Esquinas" because --
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
"Cinco Esquinas."
>> Marie Arana: -- we didn't know
it would publish in time for this.
But your writing spans from -- as
it says, from fiction, to drama,
to journalistic opinion,
to political commentary,
to literary criticism.
And in fiction alone it
ranges from novels of ideas,
to picaresque novels, to
thrillers, and mysteries,
and novels that are set in 20th
century history in a most kind
of stark and powerful way.
In other words, you wear
many hats as a writer.
There are many hats that you wear,
and you have learned to wear all
of them in sort of an
extraordinarily, masterly fashion.
Which of those hats would you
say represents the true Mario
Vargas Llosa?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Oh,
I think all my books
represent what I am, no?
Well, Borges -- Jorge Luis Borges,
said something that I think is very,
very real, that when
you look yourself
at the mirror you don't
know how is your face.
Others know immediately and
say, "Well, you are awful.
You are very handsome."
But you don't know.
And I think that is what happens,
at least to me, with my books.
I don't know the real
value of my books.
I work very hard.
I enjoy. I suffer sometimes
writing these books.
But I never know exactly
what I have achieved,
you know, with these books.
Even when a book has some
success and receives good reviews,
you are never sure if this is
exactly what the book represents,
because you know that the
only way would be to wait,
to wait if this book, these books
are able to transcend the proof
of time, which I think is
what definitely decides
if what you have done is
worthwhile or not, no?
>> Marie Arana: There's also some --
a phenomenon that happens, I think,
when you release a book into
the world, is there not,
that you have actually no concept
of how it will be received?
And people will receive it
in very many different ways.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Very
different ways, of course.
>> Marie Arana: And you
hear about this, then,
from them, from the audience.
How has that experience
been for you?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Well, what
has happened to me several times is
that the book may be successful
or not, but in general the way
in which the book is received
is very surprising, but in many,
many cases the idea that I had
of the book doesn't coincide
with the way in which the book was
received by critics or by the --
by just readers, you know.
And I suppose the reason is
because, the example of Borges
and the mirror is that you don't
really know exactly what you have
achieved when you write a book.
You would like to be successful.
You would like this book to justify
all the time that you have invested
and the energy that you
have invested in writing it,
but actually you never know.
And this is the great enigma, I
think, that all writers have respect
of his -- their own work.
>> Marie Arana: Absolutely,
absolutely.
You have thought deeply,
Mario, about power.
And here you are in the
heart of Washington,
which represents political
power, at least in this country.
And this is something that,
judging by your works,
whether they be serious, or funny,
or whether they be large-scale
or intimate, or whether they
even be historical or set
in the modern day, concerns you.
Power concerns you.
That concern was present
in "The Green House."
It was present in "Conversation
in the Cathedral," to be sure.
Present in "Feast of the
Goat," "War of the Worlds."
We can go right through it, and it
is really in very special evidence,
I think, in your most recent
novel, "Cinco Esquinas."
What is it that draws you to power?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Well,
I think that literature
in general is something that
represents a kind of counter-power.
It's something that the
authors not necessarily know.
But I think every good book,
a good novel, a good play,
a good poem is something
that defends us readers
against the potential danger that
there is in all kind of power.
I think the power is something
that potentially represents a kind
of danger for things like
freedom, human rights,
the basic rights of the individual.
And we are not always aware of this.
And I think there is nothing
like literature to make you aware
of the dangers that the
different kind of powers
that are around us represent.
And I think that is the most
important social function
of literature, to develop in
us a kind of critical attitude,
to critical spirit,
particularly vis-à-vis the powers
that organize society and establish,
you know, the institutions
that rule, you know,
the life in society.
For that reason, I think
literature is extremely important,
not only because the pleasure
that we receive from books,
from achievements and
books of literature,
but also because literature
develops in us a kind of [speaking
in foreign language] --
how would you say this,
[speaking in foreign
language] -- suspicious?
>> Marie Arana: Yeah, yeah.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Suspicious
about the work as it is, you know.
That is the reason why all
the ideologies or systems
that have pretended to control
life entirely are very suspicious
of literature and establish
systems of censorship or control,
because they feel,
and I think rightly,
that in literature they have a
kind of enemy of this appetite
to control everything
and to organize life
in such a determined way.
I think in a free country,
in a country with laws
that protect the citizens,
this function of literature
is not perceived.
But in any country in which
freedom has started to shrink,
I think literature immediately shows
itself as something that is there
to defend, you know,
these basic human rights
and to defend the citizens
against the excessive powers
that can reduce our freedom and can
even transgress our human rights.
And I think this aspect of
literature is extremely,
extremely important if we want
to have free societies,
democratic countries.
Literature is extremely
important also
in this civic and political sense.
>> Marie Arana: That's a
wonderful way to put it, yes.
[ Applause ]
I wonder to what extent you were
sensitized to the whole notion
of power in your experience in the
military school, Leoncio Prado?
Was there a sense then that there
was a kind of ominous power at work?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Well, I --
you know, Marie, I
discovered authoritarianism
when I met my father
for the first time.
I was 11 years old.
Until then parents were divorced.
And as my maternal
family was very Catholic,
they were ashamed of this divorce.
And so he told me that my
father was dead, you know.
And one day suddenly when I was
11 years old, my mother told me,
"You know that your
father is alive, no?"
And I think I haven't yet
recovered, you know [laughter].
From the impression that I
had when my mother told me
that my father was alive.
So I said -- I asked to her, "And
when I'm going to meet my father?"
And she told me, "Right away.
Immediately."
We go to the hotel, and he is there.
And I went to live with my father.
My father reconciled and
-- my parents reconciled.
And with my father I
discovered authoritarianism.
He was a very authoritarian
personality.
And I remember very well how
my life changed completely
since I went to live with my father.
I discovered things that I didn't
know that they exist, you know.
Fear, for example.
I had such a fear with
this strange man,
because he was completely
strange in my life.
And I think that the military school
was just a continuation of the kind
of authoritarianism that I had
at home because of my father.
And I think the -- probably it was
there, during those early years
of my adolescence, you know, that
I started to hate dictatorships,
any kind of dictatorship.
And this, I think, has been
something recurrent in my life,
in my writings, and the way in
which some authorities exercise
with brutality, with abuse,
without respecting, you know,
the most elementary forms in life
is something that I cannot resist.
And I think this explains,
probably, why in so many books,
in so many novels, the theme of
authoritarian power is central,
is something that has been repeating
itself in what I have written,
because in my life this is something
that has produced in me this kind
of protest of rebellion, you know,
against any kind of abuse of power.
>> Marie Arana: Well, if you're
talking about power you --
and you're talking about
authoritarian power,
you're also talking about
corruption eventually.
And you're talking about -- also
about rebels against the power,
which is what you attribute the
great work of literature doing.
But you've thought
deeply also about rebels.
And you've -- I'm talking now about
Flora Tristan, for instance who --
the Peruvian grandmother
of the artist Paul Gaugin,
who was a feminist revolutionary
and a character in your novel
"El Paraiso en la Otra
Esquina," which was "The Way
to Paradise" it was in English.
And I'm thinking about
also Sir Roger Casement
who in a way was a
rebel in his own right,
the hero of "Dream of the Celt."
And I'm thinking, too, about
la Retaquita, who is Julieta,
the heroine of your most
recent book, "Cinco Esquinas."
And these were all people who
are after some kind of truth.
They are trying to right
a wrong, as it were.
And they're bucking a
whole system to do it.
So rebels also, aside from power,
are very much a theme in your work.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Oh, without a doubt.
I -- these kind of
characters I admire very much.
I mean, people who are not --
who don't accept the world as
it is and want to change it.
Usually they want to change
it in the good way, in the --
to reduce sufferances,
to reduce misery,
to defend freedom against
oppression.
But in certain cases there
are rebels who are --
who have a very wrong
idea of what they want
to achieve with the rebellion.
But it doesn't matter.
Even if they are wrong, and
even if they fail completely
in what they try to do, there is
something that I think is admirable
in these people who are not
conformist and that consider
that the world should change
in order to be a better place,
at least for some people.
This kind of character
I admire very much,
and I think that is the reason why
in my novels sometimes I
am not totally conscious
of what I am doing.
But in general when I have a
perspective of what I have done,
I discover that this kind of
character is recurring in my novels.
Sometimes they came from history.
In other cases, I invented
characters.
But the attitude that
they represent,
rebellion against the world
as it is, I think is something
that I am deeply attached.
And in a way I think that this
is also a consequence of my love
of books and of literature
and fiction.
I think the books gave me
since my first readings
when I was very young this idea of
the adventure, life as an adventure.
Life as an adventure to change
life for the better, no?
I read Alexander Dumas, the history
of the musketeers, for example,
and I remember the way in which
I enjoy and I identified myself,
you know, with the musketeers,
with d'Artagnan, with Porthos,
with Aramis, and afterward
when I started
to read more important books,
you know, Moreau, Faulkner,
the kind of heroes that are
[inaudible] a kind of war
with the world as it is were heroes
with which I identified
myself immediately.
So it's not strange that
I have tried in my novels
to produce these kind of characters.
>> Marie Arana: To adopt
the adventure, yes.
And you do -- and you do, indeed.
For whom do you write, Mario?
For whom -- who is -- what you write
your fiction or your nonfiction,
do you have someone in mind?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: No.
>> Marie Arana: Who is that person?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: I don't
think I am thinking in a reader --
in a particular kind of reader
when I am writing a novel.
No, for me, to write a novel is
something, I repeat, very solitary.
I secluded myself in a world
which came from memories,
images from the memory
which produce inventions,
which produce another
images, which are invented.
But the point of departure is
something -- it's always memory.
It's images that are
preserved in the memory.
Images that were produced by
experiences, by living experiences,
and then are always
the point of departure
for the imagination, for invention.
But I don't think I have a
particular kind of reader
in which I am thinking
when I am writing, no.
What I try to do, of course --
and I think this is something
that many writers try to do
when they are writing -- I try
to divide myself in the reader
that is reading what I am writing to
see if the techniques are effective
and can really persuade the
reader of what they say.
But I think this is a very
personal kind of reader,
and I don't think I have a
particular audience in mind
when I am writing a book.
It's different when I write an
article or I write an essay.
That is different, because that
you try to reach a kind of public.
But this is not the case
when I write fiction --
>> Marie Arana: When
you write fiction.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: -- at all.
>> Marie Arana: Yes, I understand.
Now you are, as we all
know from just listening
to the Ambassadors here who -- or
the list of names who have come
to pay you tribute
and to hear you --
that you're a citizen of the world.
You have -- you're Peruvian,
but you live in Spain.
You hold Spanish citizenship.
You have lived in Britain.
You've lived in France.
And you are read and
loved the world over.
I can't even count the
number of languages
that you're translated into.
So my question to you is do
you think of yourself in terms
of allegiance to any kind of
nationality, any kind of culture?
Where are your allegiances?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Well, as you said,
I think I have become
a citizen of the world.
The -- particularly the world
in which we live now permits
this kind of world citizenship.
But I think for a writer
that our basic experiences,
which are the major source of
his fantasy, or when he writes.
And I think in my case,
these basic experiences,
I had it when I was young,
when I was an adolescent,
and probably that is the reason
why, in spite of living outside Peru
so many, many years, I am
always returning directly
or undirectly [sic] to Peruvian
themes, to Peruvian environments,
to Peruvian geography, and to
Peruvian language, you know,
the way in which we speak
the Spanish is something
that is intimately linked to the
kind of Spanish that I write.
And I think the reason is
because the basic experiences
that form my personality
were experiences that I had
in Peru when I was young, no?
>> Marie Arana: There -- I think
it was Garcia Marquez who said,
"The writer that I became was a
fully-formed mind, in a sense,
or heart," by the time
he was eight years old.
The idea that you -- your --
those first experiences --
and for you it was in -- you were in
Bolivia, and then you were in Piura.
You were moving around as a child.
So you have this natural, for as
long as you can remember perhaps,
a kind of fluid relationship
to the world, would you say?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Yes, that is true.
And on the other hand, I feel the
basic experiences were not literary.
My literary experiences are
much less universal, you know.
I -- for example, I remember
the way in which I was impressed
when I was -- I don't know --
12, 13 years old watching a play
by Arthur Miller, "Muerte de un
Viajante," "Death of a Salesman."
>> Marie Arana: Salesman.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
And I was so impressed
because it was the first play which,
like a modern novel, could change,
you know, time, spaces,
in a very audacious way.
And immediately I wrote my first
play after the experiences,
the strong experiences which
was for me to see this play.
And then, for example, a
French writer, Flaubert,
marked me very, very
much as a writer.
I think I discovered the
kind of writer that I wanted
to be reading "Madame Bovary."
I discovered that realism was
something very different of the kind
of realism that was at that
time in Latin America popular.
Not a realism that was negligible
with form, with aestheticism.
No, the contrary.
Flaubert could match realism and the
research of beauty, of perfection,
the kind in which he wore
the language to reach the --
les mots justes, the right word.
You know? Was such that could match
perfect realism and aestheticism.
And so, I think I owe
enormously to foreign writers,
not only Latin American writers.
It was the case of
Faulkner, for example.
I remember when I read the first
novels by Faulkner, I was entranced.
I discovered that the novel could
be so rich if you use, you know,
all these techniques
that Faulkner was using
with such easiness in his novels.
I remember how important it was for
me to read, for example, Malraux,
the way in which Malraux described
masses of people moving, acting.
It was really extraordinary and --
so my literary training is much more
universal, is not Latin American.
No. But the basic experiences, yes,
I think Latin American and Peruvian.
>> Marie Arana: Mm-hmm.
Absolutely.
You know, in a symposium, ED
Grossman, your translator, who,
unfortunately, couldn't be here.
But she sent her paper and her
paper was quite interesting
because she said that if
you weren't a novelist,
you would be an archeologist.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
An archeologist?
>> Marie Arana: Yes.
Because your work is to sort of
dig and excavate history, reality.
And then, she said something
else very interesting
and I want you to react to it.
She said not only would
you be an archaeologist
if you were not a write, but that
you also have this extraordinary
voice that has come from
Cervantes, through Faulkner,
and I would add Flaubert,
to the work that you do,
and that you're actually employing
all of these voices in what you do.
So are -- would you be interested
in a job in archeology, perhaps?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Well,
archeology in this sense, yes.
But to study bones, no.
I don't think so.
No [laughter].
I'm sorry.
I hope there is no
archaeologist in the audience.
I am much more interested
in the living world
than the world of the past.
>> Marie Arana: There's something
else that I wanted to go back
to Flaubert, because there's
something very important
that I think connects
you to Flaubert,
and that is that Flaubert
thought and wrote about the fact
that writing is very hard work.
It is -- I think you said arduous
labor and if you do it right,
you're -- you don't just
stop with writing a sentence.
You -- the labor comes
actually after that point.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Absolutely.
I think that is the example of
Flaubert, which is very encouraging.
I think you discover with Flaubert
something extremely important.
If you are not born genius-- if
you are born a genius, no problem.
But when you discover
that you are not a genius,
this can be very discouraging for a
writer, if you want to be a writer.
Well, that was the case of Flaubert.
Flaubert was not a genius.
Flaubert started writing
very bad things.
You know? Imitations of the
fashionable writers of his time.
But he wanted to be a
great writer and he decided
that he would become a great writer.
And as he was not a genius, he
decided to replace, you know,
this natural force of
creativity with hard work.
And this was for me
extremely important.
As important as to discover
that realism could be a kind
of literature that at the
same time was extremely formal
with great preoccupation for the
techniques and for the language.
The way in which Flaubert built his
talent, working with such obstinacy,
with such perseverance, and imposing
himself kind of seclusion, you know,
for months and for years,
is something extraordinary.
And he became a very great,
great writer without
being a natural genius.
And that, I think, is a great
example that Flaubert gave us
to the writers that we
are not born genius.
You know? That working very
hard, being extremely self-critic
of what you do, being
obsessed with the idea
of improve what you have done, you
can really produce great literature.
And I think this is a
fantastic example, you know.
The case of Rimbaud, for
example, is the opposite.
Rimbaud, when he was 14 years
old, was writing master works,
poems which were absolutely
revolutionary and perfect.
And this can be very depressing if
you don't have this natural force
of creativity that Rimbaud had.
Well, Flaubert is much more
human because he's something
that working very, very hard could
reach the kind of originality,
creativity, that the natural born
genius that was Rimbaud produced.
You know? That is why I think to
read not only the novels of Flaubert
but the correspondence of
Flaubert, particularly the letters
that he wrote every day to
his lover, Louise Colet,
when he was writing "Madame Bovary,"
is something absolutely
extraordinary.
Because you see, reading these
letters, how he was able to build,
to construct his talent, his genius.
You know? Working very, very
hard, not accepting, you know,
what he has done, convinced
that this could be
improved, could be perfected.
You know? And I think this is
something that helped me very,
very much when I was
writing my first novels.
You know?
>> Marie Arana: The
notion that you need
to rewrite as much as you write?
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Yeah.
>> Marie Arana: Yes.
Now, I want to take you away from
literature a little bit and take you
to the Mario who is the political
commentator in "El Pais."
We know -- well, we're fortunate
to live, I guess I should say,
as the Chinese saying
goes, in interesting times.
We've -- there's a
Peruvian election afoot.
We had the first -- primera
vuelta, the first round yesterday.
There's a very interesting
election going on in this country
as well [laughter], as it happens.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Interesting
means many different things.
>> Marie Arana: Yes.
It happens every 20 or so
years, my husband tells me.
So I need to prepare
for the next one.
But it's been very,
very extraordinary,
really, these two elections.
Tell us your thoughts about the
situation in -- first in Peru.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Well, it's very,
very interesting what's been
happening in Peru since the end
of the dictatorship of
Fujimori, year 2000.
Since then, we have had
democratic governments.
>> Marie Arana: Right
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Borne out of free elections.
And different kind of governments.
But because there is a very
large consensus in Peru in favor
of politically democracy and,
for the first time, I would say,
in our history, a large consensus
about the economic policy.
Market the economy, integration
with the markets of the world.
And all this has been produced
an extraordinary progress
in material terms.
>> Marie Arana: So living.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Extreme
poverty has reduced dramatically.
The middle classes
have been growing.
Foreign investment is coming
to Peru with enthusiasm.
And this has produced a real,
real progress in the country.
What will happen if Keiko
Fujimori wins the election?
She is the daughter of the dictator,
one of the most corrupt dictators
that we have had, and also
cruel, not because the crimes
that were committed during
the Fujimori 10 years
in power were enormous.
Well, it will be a catastrophe for
the country because, first of all,
the triumph of Keiko
Fujimori would mean a kind
of reindication of the dictatorship.
The dictatorship would
be legitimitated, no,
by the Peruvian electorate.
Prisons where all the Fujimoristas
are paying their crimes and their --
would be free and will pass
immediately to be part of the power.
The division that this will produce
in the country will be enormous.
And of course, not only the
economy, but the social stability
that the country has enjoyed
in the 2000 will disappear.
So my great hope is that in
this second round election,
second election, will -- Pedro
Pablo Kuczynski will win.
It will be difficult because
the difference is large,
but I think it's possible.
My hope is that blindness will
disappear, at least in part,
and Peruvians won't commit,
you know, the big, big,
big mistake to elect Keiko Fujimori
because I think the
consequences will be politically
and also socially and
economically disastrous for Peru.
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Arana: Thank you for that.
I want to take you, because we need
to wrap this up, to your reflections
from your -- this grand promontory.
I mean, exactly two weeks ago today,
you celebrated your 80th birthday.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Alas.
>> Marie Arana: Happy birthday.
[ Applause ]
And a year before that, you said
-- and this is absolutely memorable
and I think inspirational in a way.
You said you didn't want
to die dead [laughter].
You want to die living.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: That's right.
>> Marie Arana: And you wanted
to be cut down in your stride,
even as you're forging ahead,
doing what it is that you do
to stay alive, which is to write,
to live, to comment, to be involved,
to be an involved person in this
world of ours, this great world
of ours that you inhabit.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: You
know, Maria, the problem is
that people think that if
you receive the Nobel Prize,
you are already finished [laughter].
This is a great homage, but you
become a kind of an institute
and you won't be able
to produce anything
because institutes
don't produce things.
You know? And I am doing all my best
to disappoint people who believe
that I have become an institute.
You know?
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Arana: I'm going to repeat
exactly what you said in Spanish,
because it's really quite beautiful.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
>> Mario Vargas Llosa: Absolutely.
>> Marie Arana: This
is a living, wonderful,
breathing philosophy of life, Mario.
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Thank you, Maria.
Thank you very much.
>> Marie Arana: And
we want to celebrate.
[ Applause ]
>> Mario Vargas Llosa:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.